this is kind of making the rounds bill
burr is out here love it
uh it's really great love it it was this
is the this is the effect
of like saying something that everybody
feels yes
right uh he says literally for a minute
on his podcast i think it starts around
like the 15-minute market ends around
like 16 and a half minutes it's it's
a minute-long rant just about how shitty
cnn is right of a channel
right and this one minute kind of
explodes
he not only shits on cnn he says msnbc
fox news he says they're all the [ __ ]
same thing they're un-american they're
treasonous
their uh ratings have tanked in this
massive way i think like
cnn ratings are down 68 or something
like that i think foxes are down like 27
too
but like without trump there's this
void in interest for the news now
nothing is newsworthy we don't really
give a [ __ ] anymore yeah
so they need trump so they're starting
to talk about trump
and then his whole thing was by talking
about him giving him all this free air
time you're going to get him elected
again
and you want it you want darth vader
because you need it for your relevance
yes like the news is this place that is
not just telling us what has happened
the news is selling attention
yes and without us paying attention they
have nothing to sell ads on
yeah so they need the big [ __ ]
attention
they're selling ads like you said and
the only way to get
more money for ads is have more people
watching yes how do you get more people
watching
let's drum up controversy let's drum up
whatever let's let's get people
emotionally to watch us because then
they don't look away
who's better at that than trump yeah the
most reliable thing is fear
yes fear and they prey on fear and
nothing terrifies like your average
like democrat liberal than the idea of
trump getting elected again and i'm sure
we've had this conversation because i
think we've all thought it i know i've
thought it where like
dude trump was a joke when he first
started running in 2016. they used to
say he had to pay people to come to his
[ __ ] rallies
but then the news picked up on the fact
that he was saying divisive things and
they gave him all the attention
in the world and the more attention he
got the more people he could reach to be
like
yeah i like what this guy is saying
whether it's good or bad or whatever i
don't care the point was people were
like oh
now this guy's accessible to me and the
more i see him the more i like him and
that is a major reason you got elected
i don't care what anybody says mage and
i think we've all probably said this
independently
but the power of burr saying it is
different because he's at that level now
also there's certain people like if you
give them more attention right
they're going to expose themselves right
right like we know [ __ ] like
the longer you shine a light on them the
more you realize yeah they're actually
kind of boring or they're uninteresting
and they're not that funny like they're
funny within
their tiny little enclaves yeah right
like uh i'm trying to think of certain
people
uh you that play like an iconic
character and then once they leave that
character
you're like oh you're kind of a nerd
yeah right the ron swanson from parks
and rec
that like he's like the manliest guys
like i eat steak all day i want meat
and then like he like was tweeting some
[ __ ] like standing up for like gay
rights or whatever everyone's like what
are you doing what are you doing he's
like
i was like a theater kid like yeah i
went through like all these traditional
theater programs like i'm playing a
character like this happens a lot with
actors
right it happens a lot of that
especially like well then they started
hiring like the actual mobsters for like
the mob roles but before that
it was a bunch of gay theater dudes who
would like mob it up and italian it up
to play all these roles this is prior to
like sopranos and [ __ ] where they
started hiring the real guys
but like i've been on set with a guy
who's like supposed to be a
tough new york italian dude and then
they do cut
and he's like yeah do you think i was
really into it i think it's not
like yeah but yeah you shine a lot on
some people and they they
change or they crumble but trump is an
example
of a guy who has been entertaining
for his entire adult life yeah he
literally had a tv show
where he just had to entertain people
mm-hmm if you shine the light on him
yep he will be entertaining yep okay
they knew that bro
they were fine with it they and this is
to what burr was saying
they want him to get reelected at the
expense of the entire nation because
they know he will entertain
and us talking about him is the only way
we can stay relevant so let's go
yeah and i don't think they know it the
first time around though i think they
were okay with it uh i think you had to
see what was happening and before
everybody was kind of in disbelief
if hillary lost but they were looking at
the data like yeah that's something
every time we do a story on him it's
going up let's do another story it's
going up and you notice along the way
he's getting more powerful he wasn't
supposed to win the primaries
[ __ ] crush the primaries yeah he
wasn't even close so at a certain point
you can make a moral decision if you
actually dislike this guy
which they claim to i'm just calling out
their inconsistency which is
oh he's actually getting more powerful
the more coverage we give them we could
tamp this down
a bit and we could not make as much
money but they can't though like their
because their obligation is to get money
for their shareholders
yes like that's why you can't trust that
news well i think that's what money for
advertising so frustrating because
they present as if they have this moral
obligation to tell the truth
yes but what seems to be true when you
look at the reporting
is that they have a financial obligation
to their shareholders
and when we see that inconsistency as a
viewer we're like dude just don't lie
just say that you're a capitalistic
business that just tries to profit by
any means necessary
if you said that run with it we don't
give a [ __ ] that's why i'm almost like
less annoyed by like this extreme left
wing
and the extreme right wing like uh news
like i don't care how extreme you are
left like huffington post whatever like
i know what you're doing
you know what you're doing yeah the game
is like what is it one america news or
something like that like i know what
you're doing i know what you're here for
yeah it's just to say whatever trump
does is the most perfect thing in the
world
right so i can look at that with like
some bit of honesty they would act like
they're just telling the truth
but like i'm not as annoyed by it but
like when you go i'm telling you
the truth and that's all we care about
we're not biased real news i think fox
news that's
that's their thing with the real the
real news come on
yeah stop it yeah but they can't they
can't expose themselves because then
because they're supposed to be news yeah
yeah i hate that sentence financial
obligation to our shareholders
because it's like your way of saying
you're a piece of [ __ ] and i just have
to be a piece of [ __ ] but like
just say that from jump street don't
well at the end of the day we have a
financial
it's just such like a catch-all sentence
it's like okay now we can't call you out
for anything you have a financial object
you're all pieces of [ __ ] that's fine
but own it more if cnn was like hey man
this guy is good for ratings what do you
want from us would you turn down 70
i mean we talked about trump when he was
here because we knew people are going to
listen
yeah but there are large groups on both
sides that like
believe that they're telling the truth
so if they expose themselves to be like
ah now we're just saying what we have to
say to i'm not
everybody i understand the reasoning
because you gotta cater to morons
but me as a person who's not as quite as
stupid as that
i'm like oh i can't [ __ ] with this
because i see through it yeah but to
appease you
then they don't lose their base they
don't have to piece me but i see what
you are and i will call it out
and that's it and i know what it is at
the end of the day you don't have to
appease me you've got to appease the
morons
but anybody with half a brain knows how
biased both sides are yeah
every network well you'd be surprised
bro
you'd be surprised like i got friends
who literally
just regurgitate cnn talking points
it's shocking like close friends yeah
yeah
it's susceptible like i've been in that
spot too where like
i'm trying to prove a point to someone
and i'm like oh yeah i'll take this
article i don't even care where it's
from
that's true and i'm touting some cnn
thing that i don't even necessarily
believe
i'm like this supports my argument but
like i don't even realize that i'm
indoctrinated that's like how how
seductive the information you might not
be indoctrinated it might just confirm
the feelings that you already have
right because we're just looking for
confirmation validation is seductive
yeah yes yes yes yes and it's much
easier to feel validated when you have a
quote-unquote news network
yeah say the same [ __ ] that you feel
like oh it must be true now
yeah those guys on the tv with the
ticker at the bottom said it yeah
there's something about the tv and the
ticker
that makes it feel real yeah you know
and it's just preying on fear that's the
the saddest part to me is that like it's
just like traumatizing people like there
are people that like didn't come out of
their house for all of the lockdown
yeah like didn't weren't running like
weren't like getting sunlight
because they were so terrified by what
the news was saying remember when we
were watching local news and it was just
reporting the news but if it said
breaking news like that was a big story
but when you watch cnn or fox news it's
24 7 it's
breaking he's always breaking the fast
ticker and the colors and they're just
shooting at you like oh my god what
today and then you're like it has to
stay on
all the time like bloomberg finance or
something you just have to keep
absorbing it and you're like
yeah jesus had this just in this just in
this
like it's just they are dying for
another disease yeah if a disease pops
up on our shores
they could not be happier if there was a
cnn producer on the flight with the guy
who had the monkey pox all over his hand
he would sit there mouth shut and let
that [ __ ]
land in america and infect every single
person so that story tomorrow
could absolutely murder the rape that's
what i have with the monkey monkey virus
which is apparently different than
monkey box
okay that there was a person that died
in china from monkey virus of course it
was like this big headline
yeah and i was like oh [ __ ] another
[ __ ] pandemic or whatever i look into
it it's like
you have to be in contact with a monkey
that has the virus
and then like the death rate is whatever
and i was like this is a non-story
why is this even being pushed and the
only reason is because there's this
coveted you know
panic if you read the monkey because
it's monkey pox and maybe because of
that also but like this story like
people die of one-off random viruses
literally every day all the time we're
not going to stop dying from coving
we're not it's the new flu it's here
every year
get the vaccine update if you want
whatever but they're going to keep it
going as long as they can and so this is
a pandemic this is crazy as long as
people are afraid and like terrified and
you can fear on that and that's where i
also what bill burr said was really
great is you are treasonous you are
unamerican in the guise of a news
network
so that's where you can justifiably call
them out like sure you can't expose
yourselves but we see what you are
it is un-american it's just reason the
solution to me is like just following
independent journalists
yeah where you find them [ __ ]
you know what i mean like
you got to do work yes work well that's
the thing like
i don't know if i don't know what the
solution is for the masses like the
other solution is state-sponsored media
like bbc well
that's the tricky thing you can't have i
guess they do a decent job of it in
england but we got to ask people in
england
yeah but um but like yeah you don't want
state-sponsored journalism because
it's state-sponsored exactly it doesn't
have to be one of them
playing every single the beginning of
every program
you